So, who's my guest this week?
It's the Chief Executive
of the International Rescue
Committee, David Miliband.
Nearly 80 million people
were forced to flee their homes last year
and that was before Russia invaded Ukraine
fueling a growing global food crisis.
Founded at the request of
Albert Einstein in the 1930s,
the International Rescue Committee
helps resettle and educate refugees,
treading a path between policy,
politics, populism, and people,
not always a conducive mix.
It's President and CEO,
also knows both government
and non-governmental power
as a former British Foreign Secretary.
From Ukraine, Syria,
Afghanistan, and South Sudan
to the U.S. border and
the English Channel.
How can NGOs act in the
best interests of refugees
while navigating governments
with competing priorities?
Here's what's coming up?
Is it frustrating the lack of
awareness and understanding
people have about displaced
people around the world as well?
Well, I think that the scenes from Ukraine
they've created in everyone
that visceral sense it could be me.
That's a fundamental
mind shift for people.
Do you wanna get back into politics?
I'm running a $1.4 billion NGO.
We are in the middle of
the largest refugee crisis
since the Second World War
and I feel genuinely lucky
to be doing this job.
David, thank you very much for joining me.
Thank you for having me.
I thought we'd start with, of course,
what you focus on which
is displaced people
and just looking at the numbers,
80 million displaced people,
now Ukraine plus a global food crisis.
We've hit 100 million displaced people
according to the UNRC this year.
And I wondered from your vantage point,
what are you most concerned about
with those sorts of numbers?
So I run an international
humanitarian organization,
the International Rescue Committee
with this extraordinary heritage.
It was founded by Albert Einstein
to rescue people from Europe.
Today, we work in 35 countries
that are either in conflict.
So places like Somalia
or parts of Ethiopia,
parts of Syria or places that are hosting
what you call rightly, the displaced.
And just to be absolutely clear,
these are people who are
forced to flee their homes
by violence and by
persecution and by disaster.
So, we're not talking about
economic migration here,
we're talking about people
who are victims of conflict and disaster
and the places that we
are most worried about
are those either that
are in the front line.
So, the East of Ukraine
is a classic example,
parts of Ethiopia today.
There's fortunately a cease fire in Yemen.
So, there's less immediate
threat to life and limb there,
the Afghan conflict is over,
but the places where there
isn't a raging conflict
but have recently been in conflict,
there's frankly not just
food insecurity, hunger,
there's the real thread of mass famine.
So, the Horn of Africa,
the Sahel region of Africa,
Afghanistan where 97% of the population,
it seems almost incredible,
but these are official UN
figures, are living in poverty.
Yemen - 17 million people dependent on
World Food Programme
essentially for support.
I'm worried that literally we're facing
a life and death situation
in conflict zones,
but also in places that aren't in conflict
but where the combination
of the after effects
of conflict on farming,
the impact of the rise in food prices,
the impact of the rise in energy prices
means that people are really on the brink
even before you begin to think about
humanitarian for health, for
education, for livelihoods.
Because I suppose you are right
that people's minds stay focused
at the point of conflict, don't they?
And then they don't know very much perhaps
about what happens next
and those points where--
Well, there are 53
different civil conflicts
going on around the world at the moment.
53, right?
And the diplomacy doesn't work
because we know diplomacy
as sorting out relations between states.
These are 53 conflicts within states
and that's where the displacement
is coming from these days.
And in post-conflict
societies like Afghanistan,
the danger is that conflict returns.
And so we are dealing with a cycle now
that we can identify the problem,
it's much harder to get to the solutions,
but what we try and do as an NGO,
as a non-governmental
organization is focus on
helping people survive, recover,
and gain control of their lives.
I mean, just on what's
happened with Ukraine
and where attention has been focused.
Do you feel or what's that like
when you're looking
across the whole picture
with your teams around the world
to see how much attention
then suddenly goes elsewhere,
and there were concerns,
and I wanted to get your take on this,
that perhaps with Ukraine, more sympathy,
more attention went there
because as some put it,
those people certainly
in the West felt like
they were relatable, they were like us.
Yes, I think it's
undoubtedly the case that
a war on the continent of
Europe brings out a response,
especially among Europeans
that is visceral in a
way that is different
than if it's in Afghanistan
or Syria or further away.
And I think there are two
aspects of the response
to the Ukraine crisis
that are very striking.
One, which you were hinting at is
isn't Ukraine better funded
than everywhere else?
And the short answer to that is yes.
Is it?
Yes, it is four, five, six,
seven times as much per head
as in Syria, Afghanistan, Yemen.
And I think that it's really
important to try and say
that Ukraine should set a standard
for the level of help
that people should have
if they are the victims of
conflict and are on the run.
And that help isn't just financial help.
The European Union
pledged to every Ukrainian
three years residency,
three years right to work,
three years access to
education in schools,
that's not available to most
refugees in most places.
Now, the second thing
that's different is that
in the Ukraine crisis,
refugees have fled to a
rich part of the world.
I mean, even Poland
is one of the poorer countries in Europe,
but it is rich by global standards,
most refugees and displaced people
in the 100 million figure that
has been quoted by the UN,
most of them are in poor
countries not in rich countries.
They're more likely to be in Uganda,
Ethiopia, Lebanon, Bangladesh
than they are in Poland, the UK or the US.
So it places strain
where there's already strain
in a system as opposed to--
Yes and it's also a site of responsibility
that is not being fulfilled.
So, essentially the
myth in richer countries
that they're bearing the
greatest burden isn't true.
And the fact that it's poorer countries
that are being expected to
bear this responsibility
is not leading to the kind
of responsibility sharing
that people like me would argue for.
So on that argument that you make,
beyond, I suppose, your funding
and where the money that you get goes,
and you talk about it not being handouts,
trying to be an empowering view of this,
with those facts of the
majority of those people
go to poorer countries,
what isn't being done that should be done?
Well, look, 3% of the
global humanitarian budget
goes on education,
but half of the displaced are children.
So, swathes of displaced people
who are refugees or internally displaced
are getting no education at all.
So, is that about
allocating the money better
that already exists in
the system or boost it?
You've gotta grow the funds.
UN runs appeals for countries in crisis,
and they are 20% funded, 25% funded,
so there's significant underfunding
even though the funding has doubled
more or less in the last decade.
Why is there underfunding?
Because the needs have
trebled in the last decade.
Essentially the number of
displaced people has trebled.
The amount of funding has doubled
and it started from a
point that was too low.
So, education is massively under-invested.
60% of maternal deaths in childbirth
are in fragile and conflict states
from which people are fleeing.
And 45% of kids who die
in the first month of life
are in fragile and conflict states.
So there's massive health
needs that are not being met.
Nevermind the fact
that only 3% of the world's
refugees go home every year,
end up going home, 3%.
So, there aren't sustainable solutions.
Most refugees are not in camps,
but those that are end up
spending 10, 20, 30 years there,
even though it was set
up as a temporary camp.
Those that are in urban areas,
60% of refugees are in urban areas.
They have the opportunities
that exist in urban areas,
economic opportunities,
but also all the risks
of child trafficking
and the rest of it.
So, is that now if you're talking about,
especially just 'cause it
all goes back to funding,
I mean, it's not all that,
but it helps everything else go.
Are you then saying particular countries
have to put their hand in
their pocket a lot more
or are you talking about, I don't know
a completely different way
of doing this and funding it?
Well, I think that there's no question
that the richer countries,
I mean, we're talking in London,
the UK's cut its overseas aid budget
despite the fact that needs are growing
and there's only two or
three countries in the world
that meet the UN's target
that 0.7% of national
income from richer countries
should go towards development aid
and that development aid
needs increasingly to be
on fragile and conflict states
because now more or less half
of the world's extreme poor
are not in the Indias
and Chinas of this world,
they're in, I mean there
are more extreme poor
in Nigeria than there are in India,
even though the population of India
is four times that of Nigeria.
And the reason is that conflict
is the great driver of
extreme poverty today.
When you combine conflict with COVID
and with the climate crisis,
that's how you get the kind of storm
that pushes people into
the famine conditions
that we were talking about
at the beginning of this conversation.
If you got all of the rich countries
to get to that level, to the 0.7%,
I mean the British governments
talked about restoring that
and it was COVID and it was temporary
but putting aside if you like one country,
if you've got all of the
countries to do that,
would it tally up?
Well, it would tally up
in treating the symptoms.
But when I tell you there are
53 conflicts in the world,
the only way to really
address the root causes
is to tackle the roots of conflict.
I mean, the reason people are fleeing
is that conflict is untamed
and it's untamed because
the world doesn't have
good diplomatic tools
for tackling conflicts within states,
it's got much better,
not withstanding Ukraine.
But is that because of a worldview that,
sorry to cut across,
but because there's this idea
that countries should be left
to deal with their own internal issues.
There's a significant part of the issue
is the sovereignty argument.
That what goes on within a state
is only the business of that state.
So, if we choose to bomb our
own citizens as some states do,
if we choose to deny aid to our citizens,
that's only our business.
Second part of it though
is in a weird way the opposite.
So our analysis is that sovereignty
is being used as a shield
against accountability by governments.
But secondly, there's a massive growth
in the number of what are called
internationalized conflicts.
If you look at Libya or you look at Syria
or you look at even Ethiopia,
there's external interference,
six, ten, twelve different
countries, Yemen,
12 different countries with a,
involved with proxies or other support.
So, on the one hand,
it's the sovereignty argument
used to keep the international system out
to keep UN officials out.
On the other hand,
internationalization of conflict
is driving the kind of
impunity that we are seeing
that's driving more people to flee.
We've got no appetite in some ways
at the same time, do we?
For intervention.
I know what you just said
about the outside forces,
but there's this kind
of thing coming together
at the same time
and you've been a foreign secretary
for this country, for the UK.
And you would've seen how
it works at a state level.
So, how do you deal with
that in a climate of,
especially, I mean, you even
see it, of course America.
I was talking to John Bolton,
the former security advisor to Trump
on this program only a few weeks ago.
And he says, Biden is just not
doing enough to arm Ukraine,
even at arm's length,
there is a concern because it's doing,
we don't wanna get involved.
So I know you're talking about diplomacy
as opposed to arming,
but there is an appetite,
there's a lack of appetite
for getting involved, isn't there?
Well, I think there is,
I think you are right
and that partly explains
the weakness of the multilateral system.
But I would argue that if
these problems aren't tackled,
you end up with more
political instability,
that in a connected world
ends up rebounding on you.
But how do you change it?
Well, I think you have to argue for it.
You have to win the political arguments.
But why is somebody like Joe
Biden not winning it then?
He said we're back, and is he back?
Well I think he's back
in some aspects of the
international system,
but in others he's blocked
and there are two blockages,
one blockage is public opinion,
which doesn't want him
to be spending his time
on foreign matters.
Second on something like COVID
where he promised leadership,
Congress has denied him a penny
of extra international funding.
So he's got one hand tied behind his back,
which in a way reflects
the domestic politics.
Look, my perspective on this is that
the West is in retreat for some reasons
which are understandable to
do with domestic pressure
and there's vacuum in a lot of places.
That's the vacuum that
tempted President Putin
to invade Ukraine,
the vacuum that leaves the
serious situation 10 years on
it's alongside Ukraine,
the biggest refugee crisis.
There are two frozen
conflicts inside Syria now
in the Northwest and the Northeast
where we have teams of people working,
but it's not part of,
there's no active diplomatic
process to resolve that.
And whose fault is that?
Well, I think the vacuum was
created by Western retreat
and a range of different actors
have moved in to take the place.
A recent policy of the
UK is with the intention
to deter people from
crossing the English Channel.
You'll be very familiar with
this to enter the UK illegally
has been to deport them to Rwanda.
At the time we're talking no one has been
because lawyers got involved
and there were human rights issues
and challenges that have
been successful so far.
If you look at the polling on it so far,
it is not an insignificant
number of people who support it.
I'm not saying it's not the
majority who do support it,
but it's not insignificant.
What do you say to those
people who support that,
who think that is the solution for people
stopping people from making
a very dangerous journey?
Well one they've been told
that the processing of the asylum claim
will be done in Rwanda, that's not true.
Your word they're deported
to Rwanda is actually true
because even if they
pass the asylum claim,
they have to stay in Rwanda.
Secondly, it's not true to say that
there's no alternative to
deporting people to Rwanda
if you want to manage asylum flows,
other countries show how
you manage asylum flows
by running an effective asylum system.
Thirdly, having left the European Union,
Britain has lost the right
to send back to the continent of Europe
people who failed their asylum claim,
which we had when we were
members of the European Union,
no British asylum policy can work
unless it works with France.
It stands to reason because
geography hasn't been ended
by our departure from the European Union.
So, there are alternatives to this policy.
That's what I would say to the people
who are tempted by this policy.
You can also find--
It sounds like you feel like
they've been lied to though?
Well, there's no question
that they've been,
it was mis-sold, it was avowedly mis-sold
as external processing of asylum claims
rather than actually the
deportation of asylum seekers
whether or not they pass the test.
But for those who want something to deter,
so rather than,
I know you're talking
about the alternatives,
but they think that something
to stop people getting
in those dinghies in the first place,
'cause they've reached France,
they've reached safety compared
to where they came from.
Let's address it.
What would you say to that?
I'd say to them,
did you know that the policy says
there will be no deportation
of children and pregnant women?
So there is an incentive
for every people smuggler
to say to a pregnant woman or to a child,
we'll get you across.
It's incentivizing the people smuggling
of unaccompanied children
rather than disincentivizing it.
And I also can trade polls of 77,
80% of British people who say
that if people have a legitimate reason
to fear going back to their own country,
they should be given
refuge in this country.
So, in the end it's not about trading--
And also I was just gonna
say of the people who come,
the majority do get the right to stay.
Well, that's a very
good point, 70, 80, 90%,
depending whether they're from
Syria or Afghanistan or Yemen
pass the asylum test.
That threshold, even without those roots
that you are talking about
which could be an alternative
to set up a proper process
so they don't have to come in that way
or feel that they have to come.
I suppose it's just other countries
are also considering this.
Denmark's looking at it,
Rwanda are obviously, the
government, not the opposition,
they're saying we're
a great country, come.
I mean, there's this idea,
there's an uncomfortableness
around many parts of this,
but why are other countries
also looking at it?
Well, because they're
looking at the numbers
and they're seeing that
there might be some political advantage
in trying to sell the idea
that this is a "deterrent",
as I've tried to explain,
it's not a deterrent.
So, the deterrent bit
won't work is your point
so we need to do something else.
We know it won't work
'cause we've seen it in other places,
the push factors that are driving people
out of countries like
Afghanistan, Yemen, etc,
are so strong that
that aspect of the deterrence
is not going to work.
What I think does behoove
really serious attention is that
at the moment there isn't a
legal route to claim asylum
if you are at the moment in Afghanistan.
Which I think a lot of people don't know
as a fact about the UK, for instance,
that they will not necessarily know that.
I suppose from your perspective,
is it frustrating
the lack of awareness and understanding
people have about displaced people
around the world as well?
Well, I think that the scenes from Ukraine
for all that they can be criticized
as being giving greater attention
than for refugees from other places.
They've created in everyone
that visceral sense,
it could be me.
You pack your bag,
you say goodbye to your
husband or your brother
or your father who's going
off to fight and you leave,
that's a fundamental
mind shift for people.
So Ukraine may have woken
people back up to that.
I think it has woken people up.
We know that from the number
of people who are volunteering
to have Ukrainians come
and stay in their house.
We know that from donations to charities,
we know that from the overall
public opinion service.
But what we know also know is that
if countries don't step up together,
then resentment breeds.
People say, well, if
people in Germany said,
well, we've taken a million
Syrians, what did France do?
Not very much by comparison.
So you've gotta step up together.
Do you wanna get back into politics?
I'm running a $1.4 billion NGO.
We are in the middle of
the largest refugee crisis
since the Second World War
and I feel genuinely lucky
to be doing this job.
I was in politics, I'm an ex-politician.
All sorts of things can happen to you
after you leave politics.
I've found something
that allows me to put
my values into action.
I feel inspired by the way in which
we've made solutions, not suffering.
The calling card of the
International Rescue Committee.
We've grown from being a
$400 million organization
to being a $1.4 billion organization.
And we've got to take the
lessons of our solutions
to health and to hunger
and to lack of education
and take them to a wider audience.
I always say to people that
I don't know what I'm gonna do next,
and that may not be a satisfying answer,
but it's an honest answer.
You will be still a keen
watcher of UK politics.
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask you about,
are you still a member of the Labor Party,
the left, Keir Starmer, Sir Keir Starmer,
the leader of the Labor Party.
There are people who are very
frustrated by his leadership
when there have been what
they would say open goals
on the Prime Minister of
the UK, Boris Johnson,
with issues around him
being fined by the police
through to other trust issues.
Do you share those frustrations?
Well, I am as a British citizen,
I am much more frustrated
by the policies of the British government
than I am by the performance
of the Labor opposition.
The country faces massive challenges,
post austerity, post Brexit, post COVID,
post the war in Ukraine
and all that's done to energy prices.
And it's not being given
answers by the right in politics
and it needs to be given some answers
by the center left in politics.
And the judgment in the end has gotta be,
how is it gonna change the country?
We're 25 years since the
'97 Labor election victory
which I was involved with.
21 years since the 2001,
17 years since 2005,
the three elections
that we won on the trot,
we won on the trot by presenting
a clear project to the country
where agree with it or disagree with it,
you knew what it was about
and then there were policies to emblemize
and to symbolize the change
that was being promised.
That is the task that Keir
Starmer has said that he has.
Do you think we'll have
a Prime Minister Starmer?
Yes, I think there's
a real chance of that.
I think he's got depth and
breadth that is important.
And anyone who tells
you, yeah, it's certain,
it's 100% chance that,
that's not the real world,
that's partisanship, not prediction,
but I think he's a serious person
with a real understanding of how to lead
and a real sense of where
the country's going wrong
and he's gotta bring that out
and take it to the British people.
Has he asked for your advice?
He's got tons of advice.
Well, your brothers in the Shadow Cabinet!
He's got tons of advice,
he doesn't need, you know,
I'm sure he is watching this program--
Well, we'll make sure, we'll make sure.
No, no, but when people
have been through things
they can reach out to others
who have been through them.
And I was also just wanted to bring up
before our time was over
that you took Hillary Clinton
for a fish and chip dinner,
I believe, recently.
More than one chip, I can report.
Good, many chips, does she have vinegar?
In the great vinegar
versus no vinegar divide,
she took vinegar.
She also took tartar sauce
and she also ate mushy peas
without confusing them with avocado puree
which for those of your
viewers who are followers,
acute followers of British politics
will know that it's a very significant--
This was in South Shields.
In South Shields, my former constituency.
Your former political home.
And you've taken quite a few world leaders
and dignitaries around that place
and you always go to
the same fish and chips?
Correct, sustainable.
Sustainable.
Colmans Fish & Chips
shop on the Ocean Road.
And so it sounds like she enjoyed it,
but I wonder as two former politicians,
have you discussed life beyond
and what it's like to be out of it now?
Yes, yes of course.
And look, she did me a great honor
in coming to South Shields,
which is an ex-mining,
ex-ship building constituency
in the Northeast of England,
where I felt embraced
by the local community
and determined to repay
in all sorts of ways
but one way was continuing the tradition
of this South Shields lecture.
And she's got an extraordinary
story to tell really,
after 50 years in public
life of some kind or another.
Does she want you to
get back into politics?
She's not pushing.
She'd be an interesting agent for you.
Agent, I would never put it
that way, she's a friend.
Well, thank you very
much for talking to us
and thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.